just got some musing on the radio I'm
not really sure of the details but it
sounds like the patrol have picked up
some poachers with gorilla meat on their
hands and so we're gonna head over there
right now and find out what's going on
[Music]
throughout the Congo Basin gorillas face
two huge threats logging and poaching
[Music]
to reach deeper into the forest logging
companies build roads the roads allow
poachers to follow and to ship their
catch to market
[Music]
at its current rate the legal hunting
could wipe out the last of the wild
lowland gorillas in a decade obviously
seen lots of pictures and books but
nothing can really prepare you for that
in reality it's warm from sitting on
this it's as if you were holding you
know that the warmth it's as if it were
alive but obviously I mean you're
holding a hand of a gorilla that was
once running around you're not going to
eat it looks like a juvenile females
most of the meat is eaten but poachers
sever the hands and feet for souvenirs
a dead gorilla can bring five US dollars
a tremendous sum for most here the
challenge is to make a real is more
valuable than that alive
I had to walk away from from what we
were founding the guerrilla remains that
had been confiscated from the cultures
because it just became too difficult for
me to stand there and hold the hands and
the smell and having just seen these
beautiful animals I'm distraught and the
scent is lingering on my hands
[Music]